to be an artist is to be suspicious of
my
and yes is probably more weary than most
she was called the grandmother of French
new-wave
when she was thirty how she must have
rolled her eyes and I imagine she is
doing that at this very moment
throughout her career she has held up to
the viewer the beauty and nobility of
everyday life not the epic canvass of
survival on a battlefield but the
dignity and heroism of the person next
to us their struggles their memories and
their value she would be the last to
claim any special status but we honor
her tonight because she does occupy a
special space she made her first film in
1954 63 years ago when cinema was still
a young art she was 25 years old
self-taught had never written or even
read a script she told herself she only
intended to direct that one film yet he
or she is today still a pioneer still
making beautiful films with a touch as
deft and original as when she first
picked up the camera female director is
another label she might resist she is of
course first and foremost an artist a
creative force a brilliant mind and
inquiring spirit a communicator when she
began she did not just make films no
woman had ever made they were films no
one was making but yet it is also true
that she was one of only a handful of
small of female directors in the world
at the time and we all know what that
represents setting out where there are
no precedents to follow overcoming
skeptics
and Prejudice facing all the extra
hurdles in the path of a working mother
that women are to still have to fight to
be free to pursue their craft on an
equal footing today is something that I
imagine she never expected so we need to
draw strength from artists like Enya's
those women who went first who took that
first step
showed the way for all of us who saw a
little further than others around them
who said I will speak I will write I
will go there that way is for me who
broke convention and freed the
constraints on the next generation those
who stand for artistic freedom to be
around and yes is to feel more oxygen
come into the room to feel that sparkle
that sense that anything is possible you
have reminded me personally of the
importance of joy the joy of being
playful and creative and living in the
moment tonight we recognize not only
your work but your life your grace and
your intellect your charm and your grit
your independence and your originality
you once said you don't catch people's
attention through normalcy I feel I
should say on behalf of all of us thank
you for being everything but normal
we're being unique
unique and daring and exceptional for
being n yes it is truly truly my honor
to present you this award on behalf of
the Academy